- I love Smithworks, you
know that, but what's this?
- Well that is the Smithworks mascot.
- That is you.
- Which is me, 180 pounds ago.
- I'm gonna use it as a voodoo doll.
- A what?
- Voodoo doll.
- And it's got,
I don't know how I'm supposed
to talk about this now,
cause there's all kinds of legal issues,
so I'm just gonna set him down there.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, I get it.
Let's toast, though,
because tonight, y'all,
is The Voice finale on NBC.
(cheers and applause)
- And that right there,
you know what that means.
It looks disgusting, but
it means pick me, okay?
Just deal.
- Everyone knows I'm
gonna win, just kidding.
Here you go.
Okay, I will say most
times drinking with you,
it doesn't end well for me, but it's fine.
- I wish I could tell
some stories on your show.
- You can't, no.
- This show would be so much better
if I could tell some of
the crap that you've done.
- They, they, they.
Just dream, just think
about what could happen.
- Wait a minute, what are we toasting to?
The finale or to Jake?
- Congratulations and Ricky.
- Yes.
- And I gotta say, though,
I'm amazed that Jake has made it that far
with the worst coach in
the history of the show.
- Oh my gosh, you are.
- That's unbelievable.
Congratulations.
- He made it all the way to
the finale cause I'm horrible.
(cheers and applause)
- So speaking of drinking,
you have so many jobs,
like myself, and you have, is
it three restaurants right now
and you're opening a fourth?
- There is, so there's
an Ole Red in Tishomingo.
- What are you laughing about?
- Well cause it's why is there one there?
Because that's kind of where I live.
- Yeah, well that's why.
- Yeah.
And then there's one in Nashville,
and then there's one in Gatlinburg,
and then we're about
to open one in Orlando.
And there's others in the works.
- That's a really smart place to open one
because of all the stuff to do there.
- There's way smarter people than me
that decide where those
things go, clearly.
- Clearly.
Did you choose Tishomingo?
- I can't believe you did a shot of vodka,
I can already tell you're
starting to act a beer.
I told them, I said, there is
no way she's gonna actually
do a shot of vodka.
- No, I do tequila, I
did tequila with Nick.
- [Blake] On the show?
- Yeah, I've done rose with
Chrissy, with John's, I drink.
- I don't mean a shot of rose.
- No but I drank, I drank,
I drink, this show is fun.
(cheers and applause)